hablamos de salud aquí en directo
América de Francia 24 más Romero salas
ya nos acompaña en el estudio mar
bienvenida buena mañana de jueves
empezamos a nuestra Crónica de salud en
Haití para actualizar la información
sobre el brote de cólera en ese país Sí
buenos días Raúl es una de las
emergencias de las que tenemos que
prestarle atención a ver cómo se
desarrollan las próximas semanas y
precisamente tenemos nuevos datos desde
pues las organizaciones humanitarias de
Naciones Unidas escuchemos
hemos visto un aumento sorprendentemente
rápido en los casos de cólera los casos
sospechosos pasaron de 152 el 6 de
octubre a casi 9000 y los casos
confirmados pasaron de 102 a más de 800
las muertes crecieron de 4 a 267 Y
tenemos casi 8.000 casos hospitalizados
[Música]
también es preocupante la expansión
geográfica del cólera porque lo hemos
detectado en ocho de las 10 provincias
del país
recordemos Raúl que la situación en el
país extensa porque vienen esos bloqueos
de bandas armadas especialmente en las
estaciones de gasolina ahora estos
bloqueos están levantando Y eso tiene
sus pros y sus contras no por un lado el
hecho de cuidar los bloqueos hacía que
la atención médica no pudiera llegar con
facilidad a los pacientes que lo
necesitaban mientras que por otro lado
hay expertos que piensan que también
hubiera podido como bajarle el ritmo a
estos primeros contagios durante esta
semana Así que ahora que se vuelve a
recuperar algo del movimiento y de la
normalidad crezcan todavía más deprisa
además también hay médicos Nike que han
denunciado que les falta material
incluso por ejemplo para terapias
intravenosas que para una enfermedad
Como el cólera es muy importante para
poder mantener la hidratación de los
pacientes y que tampoco tienen vacunas
no recordemos hay una vacuna contra
cólera que existe que ahora mismo hay
cassette mundial que está afectando no
solo Haití sino los 29 países que este
año han declarado brotes de cólera En
comparación con 20 países del año pasado
habladas de comparación o Cómo podemos
comparar mar este brote de cólera con el
que hubo en el 2010 en Haití sí es para
irnos haciendo una idea de En qué vamos
no recordemos que ese brote del 2010 que
también se extendió un poquito antes un
poquito después fue una de las peores
tragedias sanitarias que realmente
atravesado algún país en el continente
americano y son magnitudes que por ahora
no tienen nada que ver no en esos
momentos en ese brote vemos como los
casos probables llegaron a ser casi Pues
eso 350.000 las muertes superaron las
40.000 hoy en día en cambio estamos
hablando de eso de unos 9.000 casos
sospechosos es decir que estaría justo
por encima de la línea aquí como vemos
de los de los 50.000 también vemos que
estamos hablando de menos de 300 muertes
muy por debajo de estas 4.000 que
estábamos diciendo entonces bueno vemos
que las magnitudes todavía está muy
lejos sin embargo Eso no significa que
no pueda el inicio de algo pues más duro
también este gráfico nos muestra Cómo
fue descendiendo no en 2019 no se
reportó ningún caso ninguna muerte y así
fue durante tres años Haití estaba a
punto de ser declarado libre de cólera
cuando pues reapareció este brote bueno
Esperemos que puedan controlarlo mar
vamos a el continente africano
actualizar la información de otro brote
reciente el de ébola en uganda como
siempre empecemos con los datos como
estamos haciendo No qué Cuál es el
último actualización que tenemos 144
casos confirmados 22 probables de eso
lleva un total en términos de casos de
unos 166 55 muertes confirmadas 22
probables 77 víctimas mortales no de
todos estos en la última semana se han
sumado solo 7 de estos casos y solo tres
de estas muertes es decir eso nos habla
de una desaceleración del brote es una
buena noticia parece que las medidas
sanitarias y las restricciones están
dando efecto y además ayer la
Organización Mundial de la Salud también
anunció algo positivo y es que si
recuerdas que habíamos hablado de las
vacunas que se están desarrollando
contra específicamente la variante Sudán
de este brote que es la que no tiene
vacuna la que si tienes la del zaire que
es la que hemos visto en brotes de
República democrática del Congo
recientes y que se quería pues
aprovechar este brote de uganda para
tanto pues para mostrar su efectividad
ver si realmente era así y también
ayudar a aprovechar Para apoyar a la
población en uganda y precisamente de
eso Ayer hablaron en la Organización
Mundial de la Salud
de anunciar que un comité de expertos
externos de la OMS evaluó tres
candidatos a vacunas y consensuaron que
las tres deberían incluirse en el plan
de estudios en uganda
David
la OMS y el ministro de salud de uganda
han aceptado las recomendaciones del
comité Esperamos que la primera dosis de
las vacunas llegue a uganda la semana
próxima
y terminamos en nuestro bloque de salud
Marc con una fecha porque hoy es el Día
de los nacimientos prematuros y hoy es
la fecha que se usa para recordar y para
hablar de las problemáticas que también
esto trae se consideran todos los
nacimientos prematuros los que son antes
de las 37 semanas de gestación y 15
millones de bebés en todo el mundo nacen
con estas condiciones cada año no más de
uno de cada diez nacimientos
estadísticamente y de estos un millón
muere porque no encuentran pues
tratamientos disponibles para tratar
estas condiciones que vienen
relacionadas con nacer de forma
prematura es la primera causa de hecho
de muertes entre niños menores de 5 años
y es uno de los problemas en los que más
se ven estas desigualdades de las que
hablamos muchas veces en este espacio de
salud No una bebé prematuro sus
complicaciones muchas veces se pueden
tratar de forma relativamente fácil con
por ejemplo tratamientos de calor
también de cuidados de infecciones hay
muchos lugares donde estos tratamientos
no están disponibles y esto termina en
la muerte de un bebé que podría haber
prosperado en otro del mundo Entonces es
un buen día para recordar estas cifras
mar como siempre Muchísimas gracias por
toda la información de salud y mañana
con más salud aquí en directo América
mañana con